Now let's take a look at the offset transform node.
We're going to utilize this to get the leg pump bones moving automatically when we
rotate the leg.
And we'll do that by converting the rotation values of one of the leg bones into translation
values.
And then apply those offsets to the leg pump bone using the offset transform node.
So let's take a look and see how that gets set up.
So what we want to do here is as we move this leg,
if I just hide the bones to make it a little easier to see.
Yeah, as we move this leg and move this foot control, we want this leg pump piston out
here to actually automatically extend.
So that it looks like it's connected mechanically and it's functioning in an interesting way.
So let's get that set up.
Because we want to convert the rotation information of one of the bones into translation
information.
The first thing we need to do is find the rotation values.
So I'm going to find the bone that we want to convert the rotation data from.
And that'll just be the top of our chain here.
So leg F R O 1.
I'm going to drag that into the rig graph and choose get bone.
Now that'll give us the information about that bones transforms.
So the rotation, the translation and the scale.
And to convert this rotation into translation information, we're going to use a two Euler
node.
And this will essentially break up each of the axes or rather break up the rotation into
each of the axes that we have here.
And if I connect this straight up to a offset transform node.
The item as our leg pump bone, which will be this one just here.
And connect up just one of these axes, which is going to be the X axis that we want to
affect here.
So if I just pop open the offset transform here and open the translation.
So it's the X axis that we want to affect with the translation for the pump bone.
It is actually the Y rotation, if I just show you this here, that Y rotation axis as the
leg is rotating up and down.
Those are the values that we want to take to feed into the offset transform.
So we'll grab our Y rotation, plug it into the X translation.
And if I connect that logic up just here, we'll see that instantly we get some movement
from the leg pump bone there.
So as we're moving this, we can see that our leg pump bone is moving.
So we have the logic set up correctly at least.
We can see that it's not quite right though, because it's kind of penetrating with its
own mesh.
In order to fix this, what we need to do is add the initial rotation values of the bone
that we're getting the transforms from.
So this bone here.
Back onto the leg pump bone so that it sets its initial position back to zero.
And I'll show you that with a demonstration here.
So if you select the bone that we're using for the rotation, we can see that we're using
the Y axis and its initial value is 44.639769.
So if I drag off here and choose add, we can type 44.639769.
And as soon as we connect this back up, we should see that shoot back to zero back to
its initial position.
So now when we move it, the leg pump moves forwards and backwards when we're moving the
leg.
But it still has a slight issue where it's kind of, if we go too high with this leg,
so if the leg rotates too far upwards, it's actually penetrating back inside again.
So we can actually clamp these values next to say, okay, you're not allowed to go past
zero as your minimum and we'll cap it a maximum of around about 35 as well, I think.
So to do that, if I just make a bit more space here and drag out of this result pin, search
for clamp.
This is a handy node for when you need to just limit the translation of something that's
being driven by, you know, something else.
So if we connect up the logic there, we're now going to say your minimum is zero.
If we leave it as the maximum zero, you see that that no longer moves.
But if we set our maximum to something like 35, whatever's suitable for your machine,
you can see as soon as we hit that extent of 35, it stops moving.
And when we go backwards, there's no longer any sort of negative movement or the tip of
this penetrating into the base of the mesh.
So that's a relatively quick solution that you can use to convert rotation information
to translation information and then use that to drive the movement of another bone.
So you would get the transforms of the bones that you want to use to drive, use a two Euler
node to break down the rotation into its individual axes, and then make sure that if you want
the bone that you're offsetting to have its initial position at zero, make sure you're
either adding or minusing your initial values of this bone that we're using.
And then if you want to clamp the values because you know it's going to have limited range
of motion, you can do the clamp node and then plug that into the offset node.
So it's fairly straightforward.